Tim Kalos all may bring this up on
around the horn the next time he's on
these Dallas Morning News columnist all
right Timmy where are we headed with the
the automated strike zone are you are
you on my lawn or off my lawn you know I
was beyond I would be on your lawn with
that I am a big guy don't know if you're
aware I'm a big tennis guy we don't get
to talk a lot of tennis on mm-hmm these
national sports programs we do because
of the lack of American interest in the
great game but certainly what what
Hawkeye has done for that sport I think
I think it might be time try that a
little bit in baseball get this game
moving a little bit does it take away
part of the entertainment I don't know I
mean it shouldn't I mean should that
really should a bad strike zone really
be part of the entertainment he's
wondering what the hell Eric Gregg was
looking at and Greg Maddux was on the
mound should that really be part of a
baseball history I don't think so but
why would we accept that why did we
accept that that Eric Greg strike zone
was different than Harry wendelstedt and
we found that that there was charm in
that and we found for years there was
there was I mean it was absolutely a
different national league strike zone
from an American strike that's crazy and
I'm nationally nationally gunfire's
could take their jackets off on a hot
day at American League outliers could
not if you go back into the 60s I mean
there were there were all kinds of
insane things I mean we should do a book
on the insane things we used to except
one of them being as I tried this is the
NFL the 14 game regular season with six
preseason games what were we thinking
then we weren't thinking or at least
nobody remembers that that it was even
the case I brought it up earlier that we
had six preseason games and none of my
guys had never heard of that before
because preseason games weren't that
important back then right but they did
it into the 70s I was talking about
Danny white about it he said we played
[Laughter]
yeah it's a is your phone you've got a
good connection here I I'm okay okay
they're not good for you you like yeah
it sounded like popcorn there but now I
think you're back there so Jerry Jones
is proposing 18-game schedule he said
that he brought this up the last time
around I know we got a few more years
with this new or this collective
bargaining agreement but Jerry usually
gets what Jerry wants do what what what
will be the negatives that will be
proposed that we won't have 18 games in
two preseason games I mean the salesman
he usually does and that's why I
wouldn't count him out I think I think
it's a long shot I think in this era of
concussion talk CT talk game safety it's
gonna be a hard sell I originally was
just writing about just how bad these
preseason games are and how everyone has
gone towards the direction of the Rams
they're just not playing starters almost
at all rams didn't blame at all but you
know I don't know about his idea that
concussions and manoda oh yeah did
fritzy heard she was busy with his
robotic voice you didn't follow up with
Tim's phone kill the robots getting
revenge on or making fun of their voices
technology yeah paying 50 back yeah or
is it proving Todd's point mmm cellular
that it's not ideal it's not a hundred
percent hey pritch he's gonna
troubleshoot this year can you count to
ten no he does his best with all these
guests where he'll go yeah come to town
and then they'll count to ten in their
guard care you're gonna stand still
you're gonna stand right there can you
do it from a landline see the problem is
is that probably he probably is doing it
from the landline but it's an internet
connection on the landline no it is yeah
like voice over IP I don't know
everybody gets their landline the yeah
through their internet connection so
there's a bunch of people on a computer
something like that it's gonna do that
good who has a house phone here I do I
don't think it's plugged in though
well then I don't think you have a
houseful yeah but it's not plugged in no
because it was it's their only reason
that we keep it is because it's if you
read the playwright Arthur Miller it's
his old phone number oh I've kept it for
10 years
oh okay and we occasionally get calls
from its family members do you have a
Paulie do you have a landline no not I
see do you have a landline I do NIC 11
nope yeah I do
people always amazed when they go oh
gosh you got one of those ball
telephones
I think we've used it like I don't know
well you know an alarm company calls or
something like that then you might do it
with that Tim camel shows back with a
better phone line I believe Tim are you
there I was remiss in not saying you
wrote that green sweatshirt really pops
today you you like it's really a good
look for you yes thank you
pops that's a TV term what size do you
wear I'll be more than happy to send you
one I'm a large I'm a large I lost a
little weight so the Lord's an ex-felon
are you sure you're a large well what
the Nick and Sam's couple nights and I'm
gonna envision you wearing this on
around the horns that kind of reading
into this like a DP logo or something
that I could yeah yeah very small I am
on today I don't want to digress too
much but I thought maybe your your
fellas could pick the winner
it's me woody Jackie and Ramona who you
got yapple you got to watch out for
she'll burn during the NBA season that's
her wheelhouse Yeah right but this is
this is August so I don't know I don't
know well you guys still squeeze a
LeBron topic in there right somehow you
guys are like skip bayless somehow
you'll get a LeBron topic there Tom
Brady will be on there
what else is gonna be on there Dez Bryan
hasn't found a new team yet right
[Laughter]
no I have not talked to anybody I have
not talked to anybody there who do I
think Scott I think Jackie McMullen is
gonna bring home the title today she's
probably a slight favorite yeah yeah
very much ejected Paulie check Vegas
odds on around the horn today and
checking all right yeah all right so I
don't know where we were but Jerry Jones
gets what you're right the 18-game thing
and and here's what I think I think
there's a lot of Merit to an 18-game
schedule there's no merit in it for
superstars who wouldn't need the extra
money and they're the ones who'd be
outspoken about we're not gonna play
extra games yeah but the rank and file
the guys whose careers last four years
you tell them you want do you want an
extra 15% on your paycheck for the time
that you play and the risk is you're
gonna play two more games
they'd say hell yes if they had a real
voice so you know I don't know the other
thing I would say Jerry Jones can't be
the guy to probably sell it unless the
Klieman we're talking about 20/20 so
we're talking two years when they're
fighting over a new CBA
I don't think Jerry and his current you
know situation towards the players he
could be the guy to argue somebody else
will have to argue at this time for the
owners what I think there's I mean these
these games are just hideous and you
know that's not breaking news but
they're not playing anybody even in the
third week anymore Aaron Rodgers didn't
play all kinds of starters don't play
anymore
no the Rams didn't you know have Jared
Goff or Todd Gurley in there so yeah
yeah I don't blame them you know if the
coach thinks that you're ready or when
you're ready then fine but I don't think
that you should be putting these guys
out there in the preseason just because
you're charging regular season ticket
prices right so yeah why are you playing
for these just as historically had a
whole bunch of these what's it it just
seems like outdated what's the
expectation level for the Cowboys this
year I think it's all over the map I
think the news lately is all there's
been bad the loss of Travis Frederick he
you know nobody has any idea when to
guess with an autoimmune disease he
might be back in week 3 and he might be
back in December
but if that's the only offensive lineman
you lose then I think we still have a
terrific offensive line you know Randy
Gregory had a big game then there were
rumors about Randy Gregory being in
trouble again and they were just rumors
for all we could tell that's always
going to be there I think the defense is
really good but I think everybody in the
NFC East I don't think there's a I think
they're all closer to each other than
they usually are I think the whole
division is somewhere between ten and
six and seven and nine I also had we had
a poll question earlier if I gave you
Manu ginóbili z-- career or Carmelo's
career Chris Paul's career or Russell
Westbrook's career whose career would
you take man whose or a lot of the other
three that's hard I'm a big Ginobili fan
I always have been and I think there was
a time he was never better than Tim
Duncan but there was there was one
playoff year and I came over which one
of the titles those seven maybe four I
think he was the most important player
on the team if that's possible at least
for a brief amount of time and win all
those titles and to have the land I
would take him way beyond Carmelo
Carmela's whole career has been about
money and happiness and you know that
it's just been one trip to a Conference
Finals Chris Paul Westbrook there's too
much left for westbrook's career but I
would take Ginobili over Chris Paul or
there were Anthony not saying he's a
better player but I'd I would take that
career with all those Championships and
be defined that way I'd be fine at that
yeah and you know I tell people it's not
the NBA it's it's the it's the
Basketball Hall of Fame and you know
when they go well he's been a great
Olympian you know a lot of these guys
you know their careers have to do with
college or international play as well
and you know I think the beauty of it is
that he's he embraced being a sixth man
you know people talk about Tim Duncan
being the the Spurs way I think Ginobili
was more of the San Antonio Spurs way
than Tim Duncan was because he had to
embrace it be a team player
and he's you know he's a star in his in
his car
tree but in with the Spurs he was
willing to be a role player right he was
like if the Beatles had lasted longer
and George Harrison had been fine to
just be George just be led Paul and John
get all the credit
knowing he could go solo and even though
he has career highly respect us so
you're entirely respected by let me let
me recount the comparison Manu Ginobili
is the George Harrison of the Spurs or
of the NBA I like to Duncan at Popovich
Tim Duncan of Popovich would be pollen
jealous all right you decide who's Ringo
twenty markers Ringo no that's that's
mean no that's that's probably not right
who's Pete best never mind I go no never
mind don't worry about it
good luck today on around the horn we're
gonna send you some DP Show swag and at
the very least you know that well I see
what Clinton Yates wears so you should
be able to sport a Dan Patrick
sweatshirt there good point right point
yes excellently
I'll wear around the horn shirt do you
have one no do you do they have any I
have around the horn hats I probably
have it around the horn shirt tucked
away in the closet I'm how about how
about the show sends me one I like a new
one Tim see if they could do that I'll
fly the colors on here okay
good luck today good luck today okay all
right that's Tim Kawasaki Dallas Morning
News and around the horn contributor for
more Dan Patrick
to the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]